et c'est un vent de contestation qui
souffle en andréloir la colère venue
d'Amboise prend un tour politique contre
le projet d'installation de quatre
éolienne à oswer en Touren située à 15
km du château royal elle contreviendrait
aux règles du classement UNESCO du
valdoloir Stéphan Berne lui-même est
vant debout contre ce projet dont il
promet de parler au président de la
République prochainement Faustine lunau
et Clémence
d'osque c'est l'un des plus beaux points
de vue sur la vallée de la voir le
château royal d'Amboise mais ce paysage
pourrait bientôt changer puisqu'un parc
éolien pourrait venir s'y ajouter alors
qu'en pensent les touristes du château
nous leur avons demandé le cadre est
magnifique et des éoliennes en vue de la
Loire derrière c'est c'est pas Bono
c'est tout moderne c'est blanc si ça se
voit c'est c'est un peu
dommage je pense que ça peut déranger
certains mais c'est aussi quelque chose
de nécessaire pour le futur même si à
une époque ça m'a choqué
maintenant je l'accepterai pour le
directeur du château d'Amboise pas
question de remettre en cause l'énergie
éolienne mais plutôt le choix
d'implantation de ce parc trop proche du
site touristique il risquerait selon lui
de nuire à l'attractivité du château qui
mise beaucoup sur sa vue le projet sera
juste en face du château des terrasses
et de ces jardins qui aujourd'hui ont
été reconnus comme des jardins classés
remarquables donc tous ces labels de
qualité et bien peuvent être remis en
question du seul fait de la présence de
ces éoliennes et de ces éclats lumineux
toutes les 20 éclats par minute pour
Marc met c'est la crainte aussi de créer
je cite un dangereux précédent en totale
contradiction avec les recommandations
du plan Loire Stéphane Berne qui est
membre du conseil d'administration de la
Fondation Saint-Louis propriétaire du
château a également pris position contre
car les terrains choisis se situeraient
à moins de 15 km du château sur une zone
classée à l'Unesco doit respecter et
bien les les les des règles sur le la
protection de l'UNESCO on ne peut pas
mettre l'éolienne en Tourette on est en
train de se tirer une balle dans le pied
simplement parce que les préfets ont des
consignes très strictes par le
gouvernement pour mettre des éoliennes
partout même là où les gens n'en veulent
pas alors il s'agirait d'un petit parc
seulement quatre éoliennes implanté ici
sur ces champs privés qui bordent la
National 10 le projet est aujourd'hui
porté par la société inergex la
commission départementale de la nature
des paysages et des sites a rendu mardi
un avis négatif la décision revient
maintenant au préfet d'indréloire il a
jusqu'au 26 novembre pour valider ou non
le
projet